hosi says 20 minutes of preparation adds
20 IQ points so true if you sit down
before you're about to have a meeting
with someone or a sales call or a job
interview or whatever and he's like all
right so where are they from or whatever
whatever and you're like oh you're from
hartfordshire I used to play rugby in
hartfordshire do you know the d d d and
you're like oh my God this person knows
it it's exactly the same as what before
we go into Canada we're texting our
Canadian friends going you know what
what have we got oh uh Edmonton is home
to the world's second largest mall after
Dubai right have I got any mall jokes
that I can come out like have I got any
Justin Trudeau jokes or we go into
Chicago and I start talking about the
architecture it's exactly the same it
seems like oh my God how deep does his
knowledge run his knowledge must be so
deep because he was just able to pluck
this out he's like yo that architecture
joke is the beginning and the end of my
knowledge about Chicago but it seems
like you've got way more preparation
than you do